oh hey this looks familiar and that's
because it is this is the new updated
fixed Samsung Galaxy fold what's up guys
to be here so a little refresher for
those who may not have heard or may have
forgotten the original story so as it
goes Samsung announced a crazy folding
phone in February Galaxy fold later in
the year it starts the press cycle so I
got my hands on one I did my first
impressions video and then I got the
phone in the studio did an unboxing the
whole deal I'll chop all the links below
in case you want to go watch those so
there were a small handful of review
units in the wild and then one by one
including mine they started breaking for
various reasons so Samsung recalled all
those review units they took mine back
everyone else gave theirs back and they
took them behind closed doors and
started working on figuring out what
went wrong and trying to fix it and of
course during all this there's all the
the doubters and the haters of course
like all there's no way they're gonna
actually try to relaunch this phone it's
doomed
it's just nothing should happen like
this it's canceled maybe maybe it's
canceled but all that brings us to right
now as you can see it isn't canceled its
back they've fixed it and I'm actually
starting to ship this thing so even
though I already reviewed the original
Galaxy fold and all its quirks and all
the things I liked and disliked about it
we're gonna take another look at it
what's different with this fixed one and
I want to show you the updates and some
extra thoughts and opinions I've had so
just looking at the new fold you know
you can tell of course it's very similar
in fact even if you paid super close
attention to the original you might not
be able to tell exactly what is fixed
about this new version so here we go
number one that thin layer that appeared
to be a screen protector but is actually
part of the display that may have been
peeled off by some people that's now
extended all the way to the edges and
it's tucked underneath the display bezel
right up to the corners and the sides so
not only don't you mistake it as a
screen protector and try to peel it but
you physically can so that's good then
too
they've added these t-shaped caps
at the top and bottom of the display
right at the hinge to prevent any dust
or debris from basically getting into
the hinge itself so if you look at
footage of the old Galaxy fold it
doesn't have these and honestly it's a I
guess a little surprising in hindsight
that it didn't have this or that they
didn't think of this I mean it was kind
of wild that the fold had big gaps here
basically before and it looked crazy
that you could just have stuff get into
the phone so it's good to see that these
are sealed off now now it's not like
liquid or water resistant or anything
with these caps but it's just a little
bit more protective than it was before
and then there's other very subtle
things like the gap the hinge makes when
the phone is closed is a little bit
smaller so you can see a crack still
through the middle but just barely
I don't think this has as much of an
effect on durability as people might say
but this is true about it and the hinge
mechanism itself is a little more firm
and I realize this comparison means
pretty much nothing to anyone because
almost nobody has felt the hinge of the
original Galaxy fold but I am noticing
it has a more firm snap to placing it
flat and then unsnapping it from flat
other than that it's still the same you
know the same wild phone that is a thin
screened mini phone when it's closed and
a seven inch square mini tablet when
it's open the same folding phone with a
wireless charging reverse wireless
charging it's the same phone with six
cameras three on the back all really
high-end two on the inside and one on
the front cover and all that means it's
still fun and it's still a unique
experience for gaming for web browsing
it's awesome for email I think and of
course just multitasking in general on
this absolutely huge display that you
can fold and put in your pocket the
crease looks about the same to me too
and I was just curious if while they
were behind closed doors if they would
change any other little things like
maybe improve the display material a bit
but it doesn't seem like anything aside
from those few things are different it's
still going to be a soft plastic because
it still has to fold in half in ways
that hard glass can't so much so that
there's a new warning on the screen
during the setup process that includes a
warning to avoid pressing the screen
hard
because it's still true that if you did
your fingernails into the plastic or
accidentally scratch this protective
layer at the top or even just press it
way too hard you can actually damage the
Galaxy fold but look at the end of the
day I think it's a good thing that
Samsung saw what was going wrong
accepted it took all of them back they
never actually shipped any to customers
and fixed it internally and you know
they actually addressed what was going
wrong I only say this because I could
easily see a world where some other
companies maybe take the more stubborn
like Apple like approach where like look
you're holding it wrong you guys are
using it wrong it was breaking because
of user error
it'll be fine just ship it anyway and
that's something I'm glad Samsung didn't
do like let's just be totally real they
copy Apple and a lot of things I'm glad
they didn't copy that it's just so wild
that this all came down to a few little
faults of the highly engineered hinge
that had to happen to make this folding
phone possible but then they had to go
ahead and re-engineer it again because
the damn users kept breaking it but hey
that's what it comes down to if you keep
a product completely and totally secret
like this and you never take it really
out of a lab to test it with real people
then the first real people that use it
are gonna do things that you may have
never thought of doing in a lab like you
know folding it with things other than
robot hands and putting it in lint
filled pockets and going to beaches with
sand everywhere and just all kinds of
crazy stuff like that
this new fixed galaxy fold is not a
radically different phone as you can
tell it's very similar it's still a
delicate phone that honestly I think
probably people are going to still break
this when they get it or a month after
they get it or a year after they get
this phone but what it represents I
think is Samsung taking a stance really
that they believe in this this whole
foldable phone form factor thing in the
first place my feelings on this phone
are pretty much the same which is that
I'm just really happy it exists even if
I wouldn't use it as my daily phone
necessarily I really did enjoy using it
it has a lot of great things about it
but wouldn't use it I don't think on the
daily but I'm glad it exists and I'm
glad that companies actually take big
risks like this still in a world of
you know maybe more iterative phones
like you just saw the new iPhone it's
very similar to the last one big risks
like this and it's clear that this was a
risk we saw what happened are still
awesome to see so I hope we someday get
a Samsung Galaxy fold too maybe next
year I have no idea what that would look
like or what would be different about it
it's pretty wild just seeing this first
one but I hope we get a sequel either
way that's it for this quick update also
do you want one of these because I do
have an extra one
thanks to D brand I'm gonna do a
giveaway of a samsung galaxy fold on
Twitter
sometime in the next 48 hours or so so
go follow over there if you haven't
already to get in on that and hey maybe
I'll get lucky
either way again that's been it thank
you for watching and I'll catch you guys
later
bass